I've got a situation  Bianca she's got a brother you told me  be hacked it was not a problem anymore  the anger isn't a problem that's his  problem  Padma raka had to mock something touch  it I knew I did it give it  why'd you kiss them all who the [ __ ] it  do that for what's this about my friend  my sister Bianca we can help you  wha-wha-wha  daddy these are the message to the king  he's not going to go away he's not going  to screw up we have to deal with him  and is about the younger what difference  is it going to make to her now I have no  idea what he's capable of anybody know  he's only in blood till you get out I  don't like this poll any of it  you've raised all this  everybody's looking for something in  this place  you